So here is my solution.
I created a new data structure called sdata,
and I get it by sorting it using the sorted command applied to data.
So that's Python notation.
If you've never programmed before,
get the notation by saying we get this thing data,
we run it through the sorter, out comes something new,
and we assign it to the left side over here--this new thing called sdata.
I can just make these things up.
And then I ask myself, "What's the right index?"
So if sdata is of length 5, the index I want is not number 3, but number 2
because the indexing starts at zero.
So say len(data) returns 5.
I subtract 1. It gives me 4.
And I divide the 4 by 2.
That gives me the index number 2, and that works for any data length.
So if I had 7, for example, 7 minus 1 is 6.
Divided by 2 is 3. It always gives me the middle element.
And then we just return with this indexing over here the center element.
This return with this command over here,
the element of the sorted list that's right in the middle.
And that returns the median.
So if I hit the run button, I get back 2.